I started to pay very careful attention
to what I was saying.
I don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily,
but I could feel a sort of split
developing in my psyche and the split
and I've actually had students tell me
the same thing has happened to them
after they've listened to some of the
material that,
that I've been describing to all of you,
but split into two,
let's say.
And one part was the,
let's say the old me that was talking a
lot and that liked to argue and that
liked ideas and there was another part
that was watching that part,
like just with it's eyes open and
neutrally judging and the part that was
neutrally judging was watching the part
that was talking and going,
that isn't your idea.
You don't really believe that you don't
really know what you're talking about.
That isn't true.
And I thought,
hmm,
that's really interesting.
So now,
and that was happening to like 95
percent of what I was saying and so then
I didn't really know what to do.
I thought,
okay,
this is strange,
so maybe I fragmented and that's just
not a good thing at all.
I mean,
it wasn't like it was hearing voices or
anything like that.
I mean,
it wasn't like that.
It was,
it was.
Well,
people have multiple parts,
so then I had this weird conundrum.
It's like,
well,
which of those two things are me?
Is it the part that's listening and
saying,
no,
that's rubbish.
That's a lie.
That's you're doing that to impress
people.
You're just trying to win the argument,
you know,
was that me or was the part that was
going about my normal verbal business?
Me and I didn't know,
but I decided I would go with the critic
and then what I tried to do,
what I learned to do I think was to stop
saying things that made me weak and now
that I mean I'm still trying to do that
because I'm always feeling when I talk,
whether or not the words that I'm saying
are either making the align or making me
come apart,
and I think the alignment.
I really do think the alignment is.
I think alignment is the right way of
conceptualizing it because I think if
you say things that are as true as you
can say them,
let's say,
then they come up,
they come out of the depths inside of
you because we don't know where thoughts
come from.
We don't know how far down into your
substructure,
the thoughts he merged.
We don't know what processes have
physiological alignment are necessary
for you to speak from the core of your
being.
We don't understand any of that.
We don't even conceptualize that,
but I believe that you can feel that and
I learned some of that from reading Carl
Rogers,
by the way,
who's a great clinician because he
talked about mental health in part as
the coherence between the,
the spiritual or the or the abstract and
the physical that the two things were
aligned and there's a lot of idea of
alignment in,
in psychoanalytic and clinical thinking.
But anyways,
I decided that I would start practicing
not saying things that would make me.
And what happened was that I had to stop
saying almost everything that I was
sick.
I would say 95 percent of it as a hell
of a shock to wake up,
and I mean this was over a few months,
but it's a hell of a shock to wake up
and realize that you're mostly dead
wood.
It's a shock,
you know,
and you might think,
well,
do you really want all of that to burn
off?
It's like,
well,
there's nothing left,
but a little husk,
five percent of you.
It's like,
well,
if that five percent is solid,
then maybe that's exactly what you want
to have happen.
Well,
so I told you that story is an
elaboration of this line,
and God saw that the wickedness of man
was great in the earth and that every
imagine have the imagination of the
thoughts of his heart was only evil
continually to question worth asking
just exactly what are your motives?
Well,
you know,
maybe they're purer than mine were and
it's certainly possible.
I don't think that I'm naturally a
particularly good person.
I think I have to work at it very,
very hard and I don't necessarily think
that everyone is like that,
but some people are worse than that and
everyone's like that to some degree.
So it's worth thinking about just how
much trouble are you trying to cause,
you know,
and the other thing you might think
about is that if you're not doing
something important with your life by
your own definition,
because that's the game that we're
playing,
you get to define the terms at least
initially,
maybe you're prone to cause trouble just
because you don't have anything better
to do because at least it's trouble is
more interesting than boring.
You know,
that's something you learn if you read
Dostoevsky,
does Tsq knew that extraordinarily well.
And so if you're not doing something,
if you're not pushing yourself to the
limits of your capacity,
then you have plenty of leftover.
Um,
what would you say?
Willpower,
energy and resources to devote,
causing interesting trouble.
And so while so I would say this is also
an archetypal scenario.
God saw that the wickedness of man was
great in the earth and that every
imagination of the thoughts of his heart
was only evil continually.
That's something to meditate on and it's
not self destructive because what it is
is an attempt to.
It's like the diagnosis of an illness.
It's like if that does happen to be the
case for you or to some degree,
maybe it's only 10 percent of you or
something,
or maybe it's 90 percent,
well then coming to terms with that is
excellent because then maybe you can
stop doing it and what would be the
downside to that?
You'd have to give up your resentment,
obviously in your hatred and all of
that,
and that's really annoying because those
emotions are very.
They're easy to engage in in there and
they're engaging and they have this
feeling of self righteousness with them
and that goes along with them.
But you're not doing this in order to
put yourself down.
You're doing this in order to separate
the wheat from the chaff and to leave
everything that you don't have to be
behind.